e
underway here I'd like our members to
all right let's get started um I would
please ask representative Kenny to lead
allegiance aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all
here
okay well good morning everybody and
welcome to environment and agriculture
we're going to get started with a
hearing this morning for SB
329 I'm going to open this hearing I
don't think you heard that all right um
SB 329 relative to background checks of
certain persons associated with solid
waste
management and with us this morning is
the esteemed Senator Howard Pearl who is
the Prime sponsor of this
legislation good morning Senator Pearl
good morning good to see you welcome
back to uh environment and agriculture
in the house thank you it's a pleasure
to be here uh always great to come back
to my old committee very much enjoy it
always look forward you'll see me I
think three times today before we're
done so I'll try not to be too boring or
repetitive
away uh for the record my name is
Senator Howard Pearl I am here to
introduce uh Senate Bill 329 which is
relative to the background checks of
certain persons associated with Solid
Waste
Management I brought this bill forward
on the request of the uh uh Dees they
had some technical changes that to a
bill that we passed last year relating
to background checks and they were uh
were able to identify some little bit of
cleanup that needed to happen and uh so
that's what this bill essentially does
I'm actually going to let um let uh the
director explain
really the technical aspects of it
because he will do a better job than I
will but um that's primarily all it does
it's a nice easy bill and I hope you
it okay then any questions for Senator
Pearl I heard a good line this morning
on a bill that was introduced one of
your house members came over and said
he'd do his best to sidestep any
questions that were brought forward so I
thought that was a great line I am
okay well consider it sidestepped I
guess uh representative Bixby so so I
remember passing this last year yes and
it seemed like it was pretty simple and
obvious um so why are we seeing it again
well this is just some technical fixes
that the department identified that they
needed after we passed some cleanup
language again I I'll let director whims
speak more in detail to that okay thanks
you bet okay well thank you for coming
to introduce this bill and I believe the
next one is yours as well it is so I'll
hang around thank you great to see you
you and so now we have SB
329 okay this for the next bill we have
uh director whimet from nhdes Good
Morning um director
whimet and if I may take this time
please we offer our condolences for the
loss of your
father thank you wel appreciate that
very
much so
um again for the record my name is Mike
whimet I serve as director of the waste
management division for New Hampshire
Dees um and as Senator Pearl indicated
um this is really a technical fix
because we very candidly we made a
mistake last year um we uh essentially
the this bill is purposed to correct a
drafting error that occurred in Senate
Bill 2 11 in the last session and um
that error was in RSA 149 M Solid Waste
Management act um so Senate Bill 211 was
brought forth last year and representa B
is absolutely right it was pretty
straightforward um and it really was its
purpose was to adjust language in both
our hazardous waste management Act and
the solid waste management act relative
to conducting um criminal background
investigations for applicants or for
permits or for permit transfers for both
hazardous waste facilities and solid
waste facilities so there were
essentially four areas of the law that
needed to be amended and we got it right
for three of them but we didn't get it
right in one of them and the reason that
that happened the original bill was
correct but we we' made some amendments
to the bill on other matters that were
appropriate and not particularly
controversial but in so doing a drafting
error occurred um that candidly I just
didn't pick up when we proofed what came
from OSS so as a result we didn't
realize till after the bill was passed
that while we got the language right for
haard Waste permits and permit transfers
and solid waste permit transfers we did
not get the language right for solid
waste permit applications and
essentially what what the law requires
is that um the the agency request of
performance history um be submitted and
and and and applications for criminal
background checks from uh directors and
officers of the company as well as well
as folks who um are you know like
facility managers that would exercise
significant control over facility
operations and when the bill came back
um and finally the final version of the
bill that got approved reversed some of
that language in a way that meant that
as it reads now we could only conduct a
background investigation on directors
and officers and not those additional
parties and of course that's very
important because for any either solid
or Hazard space facility you want to
make sure the people who really have
control over what's happening there are
are upstanding citizens that don't have
a criminal background um so in essence
what this bill will do is to correct
that language so that all four sections
of the statutes read identically and
that we can properly conduct criminal
background investigations on um
applicants for solid waste facilities
and I'm happy to take any
questions so there were four places in
the law where this had to be changed and
we only
really well we we messed up one part
exactly okay yeah representative Bixby
so if I read correctly the the bill and
how it was changing things basically the
language that was supposed to be on
something like line six got put on line
three instead and it's just moving the
language to the right place in the
paragraph well stated yes okay um I
would you have any objection if we were
to uh exec this today none whatsoever
okay thanks okay representative ger
thank you madam chair thank you director
for taking my question so I I guess I'm
a little confused looking at at the
language it's perhaps I'm getting this
wrong so please correct me if I am that
it it it looks like effectively it's
changing the the um background check
from a sha to a May by striking
the long dependent clause which begins
at the end of line five and placing it
in the passage which begins at line
nine it's changing it from the
application information shall
include
to upon the request of the department so
it's not a shall that becomes a May at
the discretion of the
department well no is that not correct
it it is not quite correct so um there
essentially two things going on there
whenever requested by the department
sorry I'm sorry D no not at all uh in
line four the sentence that starts on
line four it's essentially saying that
the applicant needs to include a
performance history of the applicant and
its officers and directors um relative
to the overall operations um Financial
Security and ownership of all the
facilities that they own so that's a
separate and a part that's what has to
be included in the application when you
go down to line nine it's and this the
the whenever requested by the department
is language that's been in the statute
for decad that that's not being changed
in any way it's always been
the written such that theoretically the
department could elect not to request
that background investigation in
practice that's not what we do when we
get an application for a standard solid
waste facility permit we do correct we
do request that that application but
that discretion if you will is not in
play wasn't in play in Senate Bill 211
and it wasn't in play in this bill
that's always been written that way what
this is doing is ensuring that when we
do request background investigation we
can lawfully do so not just for officers
and directors but also for partners
individuals or entities having
managerial supervisor supervisory or
substantial decision-making Authority
and responsibility for management and
operations of the facility so without
that as as it currently reads and as it
was incorrectly amended um last year we
could only ask for such an investigation
on officers and directors which is not
adequate in our in our view and it's not
consistent with the way the statute has
has read for many years okay thank you
very much that I I just was a little
confused but you cleared it up for me so
I appreciate that representative nap I'm
sorry okay representative Murray thank
you madam chair um thanks for taking my
question I did want to just clarify if
we are considering potentially executing
it today um that there is no fiscal
impact because it it appears
that nothing would change it's either
the fiscal node has fallen off or
there's nothing that has changed that
would impact that process right I I I I
I mean I suppose you know I mean the
fiscal impact uh is really the the the
the applicant is required to pay a fee
that New Hampshire State Police conducts
these background investigations and the
applicants required to pay a fee
associated with that that that New
Hampshire State Police administer it's
not administered under this statute um
and then but basically the the whole
reason the bill came about last year was
that it was brought to our attention
that the language that had long been in
our statute really didn't comport with
what the U the federal FBI the Federal
Bureau of Investigations wants to see
when they're going to make access to
their National Crime database so this is
really just making sure that our state
language meets the very specific
requirements that they have so that we
can lawfully and appropriately request
these National back background
investigations representative
Howard thank you madam chair um so just
further clarification so it sounds like
the first part talks about who's in the
application and the second part is is
sort of at the will of the of the
department is that correct um I I think
that's a fair a fair statement
sure okay representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question at what time in the process
would you say these background checks
are instigated sure great question once
we are confident that we have a complete
application so that's it's an
application that we are in a position to
review and act on we would request that
it it typically those that information
and and for privacy purposes the
information is actually submitted
directly to the Department of Justice
not to the agency so we're not managing
you know the they fill out a very
specific and somewhat probing form about
their finances and their history and
such we don't receive that that goes
directly to the Department of Justice we
just simply send a memo and say please
conduct an appropriate background per
performance history and background
investigation on the following parties
and then the Department of Justice
conducts that investigation thank you
would I followup yes thank you madam
chair would you say that this change and
perhaps the previous Bill makes the
process more protective for the state as
we review these very important
applications and permits it does in the
sense that if we didn't make the change
there was going to be discomfort on the
part of the Department of Justice that
they could conduct these background
investigations so we wouldn't be able to
conduct them and then and and I think it
does provide a level of protection I
will say that in my tenure as director
we have denied one Hazardous Waste
Facility permit application because one
of the applicants for that permit had a
criminal background um that we thought
um made them ineligible and disqualified
them for from operating fa very much
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and just to clarify so when these
application uh background checks go to
the doj if there is an issue the doj
then notifies you yes they they submit a
report to us on the the results of their
investigation
okay any other questions from the
committee
seeing none I want to thank you director
whims for your testimony on this
Bill thank you madam chair yeah um
anything else the
committee has here
um yeah uh then I would like to close
the hearing for
sb329
there and
um yeah uh representative Bixby are you
uh inclined to exec this bill at this
time I would be ined to ex this at this
time okay hoping that someone else would
before good all right well I'm going to
open the ex an exact section for SP 329
and I would entertain a motion
representative
kraton yes mam chair I recommend uh I
move oop pass onb 32 your mic please
thank you madam chair I move ought to
pass on SB 329 do I hear a second
representative Bixby I'll second that
you like to speak to your motion
representative
kraton yes ma'am based on the testimony
we just we just heard I see no reason
not to ought to
pass okay any other comment
question what he said what he
said all right wonderful uh then I would
direct the uh clerk to call the role on
uh this a to pass motion thank you madam
chair this is an OTP on sb329
representative kraton I represent coma
yes represent Davis yes represent Kenny
yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent Duty
jamana oh I think somebody's got there's
on that
shouldn't they're all green mine's red
turn off May no oh now mine appears to
be on oh no it's
red represented
Jama and yes
[Laughter]
Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
yes 140 motion passes shall It Go on
consent I see no
reason for it not
to so thank you very much appreciate it
everybody I'm going to close out the
exact session on uh HB uh SB
329 and uh we have um SB 587 coming up
at
11:00 so we have a little 15minute
breather here if anybody needs a bio
whatever
e
okay
all
right I am now going to open up our
hearing on S SP
587 relative to animals brought into the
state and with us today this morning
again we have the esteemed Senator
Howard
Pearl who who is the Prime sponsor and
we'll be introducing this bill to our
committee good morning again good
morning again chairwoman Aaron and
members of the committee for the record
I am Senator Howard Pearl representing
District 17 and I live in the Great town
of Lowden I am here today to introduce
Senate Bill
587 and this is a pretty simple bill
that came as a request from the rescue
community and we worked in collaboration
with the the uh dog owners groups in New
Hampshire as well as with commissioner
Jasper and uh Dr Crawford from the
Department of a to come up with the
language that you have in front of you
which simply allows for uh the CH slight
change to the quarantine rules that when
animals are traveling into the state
they have as you all know they have to
uh go through a mandatory quarantine
when they come in from other states and
this would just simply allow animals
that had traveled together you know
could be a litter of puppies or or you
know liter of any animal there that's
subject to the quarantine that when they
come in um they've been travel
companions along the road the whole way
and currently they would technically
have to be separated when they came here
to uh to meet the quarantine
requirements and this would just simply
allow them to uh stay together for that
quarantine period while they were here
and and the uh the Commissioner's Office
Department of bag was fine with that it
gives them the authority to allow it it
doesn't say it has to happen but it
allows them to do it so in a nutshell
that's what the bill does another
another simple change and hopefully
you'll see your way to pass this one as
well thank you Senator um Pearl uh
representative NAB you have a question
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um the age
restrictions is there a definition
around that or is that just I'm sorry
say it once more the question about or
the comment about age restrictions in
the bill um is there more detail about
that in line eight
line8 to share primary
enclosures so I may have a different
version of that oh there we go sorry I
have two different versions okay uh we
made a slight change um I'm trying to
remember there was a reason we put that
in and I apologize Heather do you
remember why we put that in the age
restriction oh that's what it was that's
right we we uh we just wanted it to make
sure that the animals weren't too young
that that were coming in so we had some
guard reils on it to kind of limit
it represent Murray thank you madam
tragus uh sort of following up on that
question with regard to the age
restrictions have we delineated what's
too young and then like where the limit
is somewhere else in statute there is
another section especially with
um there gosh I'm trying to remember
there is uh there is another area that
does that I'll make sure I get a clearer
definition for the committee on that if
you want one because I I don't remember
the exact specifics to it so I have a
question as to um this is just in
reference to litter
mates right this what about animals that
come together just in a group yeah this
just kept it to littermates L thinking
more of you know litter of puppies or a
litter of kittens or something that had
come in that they could stay together as
they had traveled you know they grown up
and travel together so if you had just
like three or four dogs that were
traveling in a trailer together those
animals would have to be quarantined
separately yes I believe so
representative Bixby you had a question
um yeah I
was I was just going to uh double check
but I I'm fairly sure that under the
transfer Pro uh requirements for animals
that um that there is a that there are
um age restrictions on that I I believe
you're correct too and that's why I said
I'll have to look at it I just can't
remember off the top of my head where
it's located in
statute representative NAB this is sort
of a comment question but we we got that
email from dogs dogs the organization
yeah and they referenced the need for
proper age restri restricted limitations
and size of um enclosures so I just want
to make you know and they had some
thought thoughts on what those should be
so I just want to make sure that lives
somewhere um yeah they were actually
involved in working with us and helping
us craft this language along with the
rescues to make sure that we get
something everyone could be good with so
we think it just lives somewhere else in
statute and it's not part of this okay
all right thank you representative ktoa
thank you madam chair and thank you
Senator
um in working on this bill
previously I believe that we delved into
age um uh at that time and really put
into statute um what age animals could
be restricted uh do you recall that I do
and I I just don't remember the
specifics apologies for that that was a
couple of years ago at least it was but
I just want to clarify that we already
have in statute age restrictions I'm
quite certain we do thank
questions seeing done thank you Senator
Pearl for introducing this bill I'll be
back at one all right yeah thanks see
you
then um I would call Heather
Faria is it
Faria thank you from New Hampshire
Federation of Humane
agriculture you need your Mone mic on
thank you got hello there you go perfect
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for hearing my testimony um
for the record my name is Heather Faria
I am the current vice president of the
New Hampshire Federation of Humane
organizations which is the membership
Collective of New Hampshire's oldest and
largest shelters and rescues um I am
also the executive director of the Pope
Memorial SPCA here in conquer um would
you mind moving your uh microphone
closer to you yes thank you sure just so
the folks at home can hear you no I know
my my voice is soft so understand is
this better yes okay perfect
um we are very grateful to Senator Pearl
for bringing this bill forward um we've
had many conversations with the state
vet and the commissioner about the
ability to quarantine litter mates
together um and what this bill would
allow for is the entially granting the
commissioner rulem authority to address
this issue in rules um with regards to
some questions that were posed earlier
RSA 437 currently um States very clearly
that um animals cannot be younger than 8
weeks of age prior to transfer into the
state so those age restrictions do live
in statute um and there are many other
requirements existing in statute and in
rules um related to the trans transer of
animals so this would simply give the
commissioner Ru making authority to
address address this quarantine issue in
rules um so I'd be happy to take any
other questions about this issue
okay um representative Duty and before
you uh ask your question I just want to
confirm that in currently in RSA 437
colon
8 section
three number three Roman numeral three
it states no person firm Corporation or
other entity shall ship or bring into
the state of New Hampshire to offer for
transfer in the state of New Hampshire
any cat dog or ferret less than eight
weeks of age no person firm Corporation
or other entity shall offer for transfer
any cat dog or feret less than eight
weeks of age so uh representative Bixby
that's where it lives and statute so
proceed representative dsy sorry no uh
no problem thank you madam chair um just
um a little bit off base with this but
how does how does this get enforced I
mean we often times hear stories of um
trucks coming up with loaded with dogs
and you know parking at a rest area and
selling them or something like that so
how does this how does this actually get
enforced and is it only um and how does
it affect people who go to another state
and purchase a dog and then and then
bring it
back so the the state veterinarian only
has oversight of things that happen in
New Hampshire and primarily over his
lienes so the our organization is made
primarily up of licensed facilities so
we are all licensed by the state
veterinarian um we are subject to
inspection um I think by Min I think
instead statute the minimum is once a
year most of us go through an an
inspection twice a year and then by
complaint so if the state veterinarian
um has concerns that are submitted by
the public he'll inspect a license
facility to follow up on those
complaints um so that's primarily how
these things are investigated and
enforced is when the public um feels
that something has has happened that
that shouldn't have uh they get reported
to the state bet and he investigates
you're
welcome representative Murray thank you
madam chair
um so so with with Clarity I think we
have sort of um addressed the issue with
regard to um age restriction and as long
as uh those are those rsas are cited in
lines 4 through n somewhere I think that
that addresses the issue pursuant to
with regard to age restriction and then
it seems that there's probably a
separate RSA somewhere where regarding
size enclosure somewhere else um that's
actually listed in rules so in addition
to RSA 437 we abide by all of the rules
in a 1700 okay um so oftentimes the
commissioner will use rules to sort of
delve into the more specific um
requirements related to Animal Health
um so there's all the RSA stuff and then
all the rule stuff that we have to
comply with perfect thank you you're
welcome representative K thank you um
did you say that was EG rule 1700 I
believe so yes thank
you anybody else I represent Bixby uh
just as a a matter of information uh the
section um four um 437 colon 9 is a list
of of things that are uh um provided for
rul making so it gives a a rough outline
in statute and then says that the
department will cover those in
rules yep
okay any other questions from the
committee NOP seeing none thank you very
much for you coming and testifying this
morning anyone else wish to speak on um
SB
587 see no one um may I have the blue
that
okay I
favor and I'm going to close out the
587 and I would pose the question uh is
the committee interested Ed in executing
this bill at this time that would make
sense okay um would I hear a motion from
someone um representative
NAB I would motion um ought to pass on
Senate Bill
587 representative kraton seconds and
representative NAB would you like to
speak to your motion um I think this is
a good bill that was supported by
different Societies in the rescue
community so um I think it makes sense
to move forward with it okay great I
would then direct the uh clerk to call
the role please thank you madam chair
the motion is OTP on S SP 587 represent
cron I representative ktoa yes
representative Davis yes representative
Kenny yes represent Penza yes represent
smart yes represent Bixby
yes represent
Duty yes represent Murray yes represent
Jama yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
yes 15 Z shall It Go on consent I see no
reason for it not to thank you that uh
bill will be on consent though and I
just want to add um for the record on
the online um portal said that there
were 11 people in favor of this bill and
zero
opposed so I'm going to close out the uh
you well and that was 11 people online
yeah
and if I didn't close out the hearing
hearing all right um before we uh I know
we're we're running really early and
we've been very efficient and um I thank
everybody for that I do want to bring to
your attention um I passed out a letter
that was um
composed from our committee to our
federal delegation with regard to House
Bill
1572 which was uh prohibiting using mRNA
technology and food and requiring the
label the labeling of lab grown meat and
food containing
insects um this was a letter that was
written um collaboration with um
representative Bixby and uh I believe
myself and others and I want to thank
everybody for the work on that uh if you
haven't read through the letter I I will
just read it briefly um to our Senators
um and to our house Representatives I'm
writing to you on behalf of the State of
New Hampshire House of Representatives
committee on environment and agriculture
the committee recently reviewed House
Bill 1572 entitled prohibiting using
mRNA technology and food and requiring
the labeling of lab grown meat and food
containing insects as the title implies
this bill addresses the concerns New
Hampshire citizens have regarding it
what is put in their food and whether
additives and ingredients are fully and
accurately disclosed while well
documented testimony indicated that mRNA
vaccination technology does not impact
our food supply articles in the journal
molecular biotechnology published by
Nature discuss a long-running effort to
genetically modify food as a vehicle for
vaccines and other
Pharmaceuticals it is the opinion of the
committee that food that is used as a
drug delivery device needs to be
thoroughly labeled and care carefully
controlled a second topic of the bill is
meat grown from cell culture it is the
opinion of the committee that any food
product derived from laboratory
culturing of animal cells needs to be
clearly labeled in such a way that it
will not be confused with meat from a
conventionally raised slaughtered and
processed
animal the bill also raises a concern
about food derived from insects we heard
testimony that the only insect currently
approved by the FDA for use in food is
the Cricut and that currently current
labeling policies do require clear
labeling of insects beyond the
inadvertent contamination threshold is
the opinion of the committee that any
use of insects and food should be
clearly labeled to make sure the
consumer is aware of what they are
eating because all of the all three of
these issues are under the jurisdiction
of federal law the committee felt that
state level legislation was
inappropriate we urge you to make sure
that these issues are thoroughly
addressed by federal law thank you for
your attention to this matter
I just wanted to know if this um uh if
the committee approves with this letter
I shall then sign it and send it off to
our federal delegation representative
dsy uh yeah just uh my copy just for
readability um on the very last
paragraph um towards the end of the
second sentence um there's an additional
a a typo labeled in such a way mine says
labeled in a such a way is that what
yours so that first a needs to be
deleted yes ah yes okay and and I would
just um this is minor but the the next
sentence here the bill also raises I
would make that a new paragraph because
you're talking about the insects at that
point not the cultured meat so I would
just make that a a new paragraph that's
okay representative com thank you madam
chair
um so I think the letter is Well written
I do have some concerns because it says
while well documented testimony
indicated that Mr vaccination does not
impact our food
supply um more recently it has come to
light that mRNA technology is actually
being used in our pork um more
specifically in the
vaccines um of the animals um and the
other thing is is and I agree with you
that the FDA uh has only approved Cricut
in our food but we have there's been
more and more articles talking about uh
worms and things like that but we
haven't discussed that
but I just wanted to bring that to light
um so okay thank
you so I I will um I will ask our uh
committee researcher who helped draft
this to make those two um typo changes
and uh I'll sign the letter and then
we'll send it
out oh I'm sorry I didn't see you
represent Murray thank you apologies no
no no that's okay okay I also just
wanted to make sure we haven't really
addressed any of the the bioengineered
food disclosure standards that already
exist and I wondered if that was
something that needed to be listed in
here because those were drafted June
23rd or excuse me December 29th 2023
mandatory compliance beginning June 23rd
2025 so I
just it it speaks to some of that in in
that section so I was just curious
represent viby yeah I I think that the
um the the way that the letter is uh
phrased especially at the end
um the the committee felt that the
legisl uh we uh we urge you to make sure
that these issues are thoroughly
addressed by federal law so in fact so
if if there is a federal law that exists
that covers these then um then great
if there is a motion if there's a move
to change that federal law then it would
be our opinion the opinion of the
committee that we wouldn't want to have
a law that changed it in a way that
would uh diminish this protection and if
there are some aspects of it that are
not yet covered then we would want those
to be covered so it's not it's it's just
really um making them uh aware that we
think that these things should be
appropriately labeled and if the
labeling is already in place then great
if not it should happen uh if there's
any move to remove labeling that should
Happ
okay all right then um thank you for
your review of this and we will be back
here at one o'clock we' finished early
and we've got some time represent fenza
you have uh something for the
committee yeah I just I'm going to agree
with um representative ktoa on that line
because just recently in the last I'd
say two to three weeks there has been a
ton of information that's come out in
the news in regards that certain states
are Banning this um spe specifically
mRNA in their meet um so I just I don't
like the well documented you know cuz
then then it basically you know I think
we're I don't know I think that pigeon
holds us to something you know I don't
like that line
so
okay
else I'm pretty good at that so I I
would be happy to work on I could
literally do that right here before we
happy this is a good
compromise
positions Madam chair yes I would I
would just say that what this says is um
well documented I believe is an
adjective for
testimony and so that is a true I mean
that is a true statement that we had
well documented testimony so that has
nothing to do with what's in the news
now and I will further say that I think
I consume a lot of news read about three
papers a day and I haven't seen anything
in any of the
newspapers um including the union leader
um that has been talking about this so I
think when you talk about it's in the
news it depends on what news you're
consuming so I would be a little
statement all right represent ger thank
you madam chair and to representative
Duty's points I and and to reiterate a
point I just made I I think this
language is well drafted and I think
it's a good compromise I think it's we
all agree on the importance of labeling
although we may have some disagreements
on some of the uh the specifics in
detail so I think the language does a
night's job of pulling the the the
committee's consensus together I also
agree with repres representative Duty's
point about this refers specifically to
the testimony which is what we did here
um and that you know short of reopening
this whole thing and getting a lot more
testimony I don't think we're going to
come to a consensus and we may never on
some of the specifics but I think this
language does a nice job of bringing us
to a point we should all be able to
agree on okay representative Crayton
yeah Madam chair I I mean there's always
room for improvement and uh if represent
pretends it offers better language I
think we should look at that and so
maybe after our committee meeting this
afternoon we take a look at the update a
language and see if that works if it's
not so be it if it does then so be it
but I don't I don't have a problem
looking at something improve
representative comor thank you madam
chair um I didn't mean to open up a can
of worms I'm not saying that it it's
long as we're not eating them that's
fine yes well don't hold your breath um
because you may be sooner than you think
um uh
but I guess what I was trying to say um
is that and it's from the pork business
and it states that uh they are using the
MRNA vaccines in pork I'm not saying
that it doesn't say that it's being
transferred to the food but they are
using the MRNA vaccines in swine so I
think um I just want to make sure that's
clarified I'm not you know I'm not
trying to dismiss what this says I'm
also but I'm also trying
to make sure that people understand that
just because we say it's indicated does
not impact our food supply that doesn't
mean that they're not being vaccinated
with the MRNA vaccine um because that is
well documented and that was also said
in
testimony okay representative Howard if
I remember correctly thank you madam
chair if I remember correctly when when
they talked about the MRNA being used in
vaccines and food they also mentioned
that it there was no sign at all that it
was passed on into the into the meat
meet represent Morris thank you madam
chair um may I recommend that if people
have additional concerns that dive in
deeper to some of these issues you send
a personal letter to your you know
Representatives but as far far as
addressing a letter that represents the
committee as a whole it should be
language that we are all in agreement on
and if you want to dive into that deeper
then um more power to you to to dive
into it and write letters and and you
know pursue that further but I think
that if we are addressing this letter
from the full committee um the language
needs to represent the feelings of the
full committee which is the labeling
should be appropriate thank you
represent and thank you madam chair and
I agree
that the language should represent the
whole committee but it should also
represent the whole testimony that we
heard and the state uh that did say that
they are using mRNA vaccination
technology in animals that are being
vaccinated that we're using for food but
it is not impacting our food supply so
transparent representative uh neb thank
you I mean I think this letter has a lot
more power coming from our committee and
I think if we Workshop it at this point
it's going to fall apart like to
representative drana's point this is a
compromise between different views on
this situation and you know I I I think
it's a lot more powerful coming from the
committee as a whole so I would leave it
as it is I think we're really opening up
a can of
worms representative kot's Point um so
that's my point and you know I don't
really want to be on it if it starts to
feel like something that's really
one-sided in its Viewpoint thank you
representative
prenza yeah I I'm sorry I opened up a
can of worms I don't I I want it to come
from the committee I just I was here for
that testimony and there wasn't a lot so
this makes it sound like you know there
was such robust testimony and for the
folks that were here there wasn't a lot
of testimony um on this subject and and
that's why some of this information is
happening literally on the Fly and and
based upon this isn't something that I'm
talking about in the union leader this
is in um some medical journals this uh
one's from specifically from the UK um
Epoch times um yeah so that's where I'm
getting some of my recent information as
well as I think it is is it Italy that
just banned this as well so that's why
I'm just um I'm just meaning lab grown
meat and stuff like that I'm fine with
the couple of grammatical changes I
resend my thing it's fine I want the
committee to move forward with this and
I'm I just you know it's the well
documented it made it's made it sound
like we had people out the door and I
don't believe we did so um this wasn't
like the glue trap thing so um represent
Howard I think that um thank you madam
chair I think that uh the final sentence
in this is what we all agree on and that
is about the labeling I don't think we
necessarily need to give an advanced
course in this topic to the the people
that to whom we're addressing this
letter that I think we all agree 100%
that labeling is the most important
thing and the the sentences that come
before that are support that very
strongly um so I I you know I think that
we should focus more on what the point
is which is to the proper
labeling representative ger thank you
madam chair and I just wanted to say in
in uh kind of reference to
representative comtois point which I
hear and and respect I think that the
the sentence while well documented
testimony indicated that M mRNA
vaccination technology does not impact
our food supply I think that that I hear
what you're saying but even from what
you just read right there's a difference
between the MRNA vaccine technology for
the swine but at this point there isn't
evidence that that is being transmitted
through the food supply which is the
language that is in the
right that is that is correct but it
wasn't well documented that it we didn't
hear well documented testimony we only
heard testimony from basically the State
Vet do telling us that this is what he
is hearing and what he has seen that to
me that's not well
documented um so that is my concern so
um it because when I think of something
well documented I think that there's a
stack of papers are many articles
telling me that I can go back and look
at science and health journals to say
that this is true and we did not have
that here in in our committee so that is
factual representative preten how about
this real quick right let's just take
out well documented while testimony
included and we're all set if we're all
okay with
that that's one
removal because it
wasn't well representative Howard you
had something no no representative H
Haskins thank you madam chair my problem
with changing it is that I'm not 100% on
board with it the way it is so I'm
trying to compromise with it but if we
start to pull back on that then I'm out
all right well the thing of it is is
that we want we we had made a promise
actually to the uh to the sponsor of
this bill that we would uh we would
write a letter from the committee uh
with regard to our concerns about
labeling issues on these specific um
issues items and
um I still would like to get a letter
out from the committee um
um I I I represent Bixby um should we
just have
a a vote
to make sure we have consensus and then
decide to send it
out I'm fine with that representative
dsy I would just get rid of the word
well okay so well documented testimony
because then I think you get then I
think you get the documented testimony
right and then I would be okay thank you
all right thank you easy peasy don't
think we need vote all right we're good
okay thank you for that I appreciate
lunch
e
set
right
okay
m
yes are you
okay I sent you an email with yeah so
just email me type it in your and send
okay committee members please take your
started I need to talk to about the
again because just was informed that I
don't we don't really have gity on my
side of term so people agreeing to it
with just a couple of
changes I no it's it's more fun let's
okay
huh yeah
uh no you did
sure all right I'm going to open up the
hearing on S SP 385 relative to the cost
of care fund and here with us this
afternoon again is Senator Howard Pearl
take it
away well thank you again it's uh great
to be back for a third time in the same
day it's almost like I live living over
here now uh for the record my name is
Senator Howard Pearl from Lowden and I
am here to introduce uh Senate bill 385
relative to the cost of care fund this
is a bill that uh the commissioner from
the Department of Agriculture who I see
is here and I'll hopefully he'll have
some convincing comments for you on why
you should pass the bill but this was a
uh request that he had and uh to put in
for some language to clean up an issue
that he was uh seeing from instituting
the uh cost of care fund and for those
of you who remember this was a bill we
put in uh
I think it was 2017 or 2018 we put into
effect to help communities deal with the
cost of confiscations and things that
occur with uh those expenses around
animal cruelty cases
so what this bill will do is uh simply
allow the uh that fund to pay directly
to the third party which often is a a
rescue and it will allow those funds to
go directly through and not pass through
the uh the budget of the town which is
causing some issues with the money
coming coming in and the way they're
accounting so I know the commission will
have further comments on the details of
that so I'll wrap it up right there and
leave it with you all right thank you so
much any questions for Senator
Pearl seeing none thank you awesome
thank you and I believe that's my last
bill with you today so hopefully you
have a good rest of your day oh you too
have fun in enr and the in the
Senate lightly off topic did you get uh
in touch with senator inis for the next
one I tried he was in a leadership
meeting and I have not been able to but
I will confirm with him that he's coming
over and one of us will for sure okay
it okay I would like to call
um Sean Jasper department of
welcome good Mo good afternoon Madam
chairman members of the committee I am
Sean Jos commissioner of the Department
of
Agriculture um you know this is this is
one of those things where sort of kick
myself being a guy who was a selectman
and uh and I'm currently a member of the
budget Committee in my town and I should
have realized the problem with this and
I don't think that the current language
is probably much of an issue for larger
towns but it is for smaller ones in that
when we
when they ask us for
reimbursement that money goes back into
the general fund and cannot replenish
the fund from once it came so it just
gets into the fund balance so the
problem is that it really doesn't
directly help in the way that we
expected it to because if they don't
have a line item equal to what could be
their
expenses they've got to find money
someplace else and that was never our
intent our intent was to say okay you've
got this problem and you're taking care
of animals and we want to help you with
your budget and this does not do that so
this amendment fixes that so that they
certify that these Services were
provided and this was the uh correct
amount and then it doesn't pass through
the town budget doesn't cost cost them
cause them a problem the second change
is I don't know who caught this it
wasn't wasn't me but in in EV almost
every statute that I've ever seen it
always speaks to the commissioner making
these decisions and this says the
commissioner and the state veterinarian
which really is not the proper way to do
it it should just be the commissioner so
those are the changes and we think it
will uh make a big difference
particularly in smaller towns allowing
them to take care of uh of abused
animals all right any questions for the
commissioner representative
Howard thank you madam chair um who who
who would be among the third party so
often as the senator said um it would be
rescues it you know I anybody who
normally takes the the Humane Societies
take in the animals we read about it all
the time when these animals are seized
and um they're they're taken in and
cared for but the towns are are build
and in many cases this is why the
animals aren't seized at all because of
the expense to the town hello sure
follow um would that include individuals
outside of Societies or or
agency
uh it could potentially it could
potentially include those if a
town uh found somebody who was willing
to take them in and they decided they
were the proper um proper people to care
for them yes I believe I believe so
don't see any anything um in here it
says a third party and it doesn't State
the type of third
party represent
vix yeah just a a little bit more
background on this and just um to and
you can confirm that I've got this right
um so uh the cost of care fund was
created uh in response to the uh Great
Dane situation in wolfboro where there
were 75 Great Danes that had to be
seized because they were being kept in
very negligent conditions and that was a
substantial cost to the town of wolfboro
which figuring out how to deal with that
cost was very complicated the it was uh
determined that there were certain
situations where town law enforcement
may be unwilling to deal with uh situ
situations of animal negligence uh uh
abuse because of the P potential cost
the idea the cost of the car fund would
to would be to take that excuse off the
table so that we would definitely so
that law enforcement would definitely
take care of the uh of investigating and
Prosecuting uh animal uh negligence
abuse and uh the cost of care fund would
allow for the taking care of animals who
were seized in that situation and then
the animals that would were seized the
law enforcement would be in charge of
figuring out who would take care of them
but it it would usually be a third party
it could be it typically it's a rescue
organization or a shelter but it could
be uh individuals who uh also have some
connection with the animals uh as uh was
written in another piece of legislation
so uh so basically the am I correct in
thinking that you're just here with this
amendment in or this bill in order to
make sure that that process can work
more effectively for those situations
that that's exactly true thank you
representative and I would would point
out that still with the cost of care
fund out
there what is to the best of my
knowledge always attempting to be done
is to work with the owners of the anal
animals to have them surrender them and
when they do that then there is no um
there is no cost to this fund or to the
towns that doesn't always happen but
often um the police or the prosecutors
will tell people if you do this you're
not going to be charged with as many
counts because they can be charged with
a count of Cruelty against each animal
that has been determined to be being
properly cared for and so that is a
method that is is used effectively and
it does reduce um often the cost to the
to the fund or the municipalities but um
commissioner Jasper may I ask um do you
know how much money is in that fund
currently you know I had that prepared
for the Senate meeting Senate hearing on
that and um we just
moved and I started started out
yesterday morning without even having a
computer and I cannot tell you that
amount right now um I think we're in the
$500,000 range I will tell you that also
because we've been packing up and moving
and because we've had the other programs
I have a number of applications um on my
desk that are probably totaling over
$100,000 for reimbursement right now
that's a ball par but um and how do how
does that fund get replenished it is a
budget item right now and there is a cap
of $2 million on the fund um currently
to build it up it has been budgeted at
300 300 to
$350,000 a year um I believe so we'll
have more money coming in in in July I
do expect that I will be ratcheting that
back based on the rate of SP of spend
but did want to get it to a reasonable
amount so that if there were another
case like the great Dayne one that the
fund would be adequately
um um funded I'm hopeful that we will
continue to notch it up for a while but
not at the rate we are at the moment do
you know whether or not the
um the trend of seizure is going up or
down at all um I don't know because I
don't have any history as to what towns
were doing before for I know that what's
going on right now in the current law um
has been somewhat of an impediment
because those small towns can't have
their their fund re re
uh refunded if you will so um but some
of these are really really
difficult
for um departments police departments or
other agencies to move forward with
seizures we've had a couple that have
been been still very difficult and and
time consuming to actually get to that
point where the animals are are seized
and the most recent one which was pretty
horrific ultimately I think all but a
couple animals were were um
surrendered representative Murray thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question um so I had
a I had a question question in reading
the current uh bill it does say that um
there's the ability to respond to such
applications within 15 days and
distribute no more than $500,000 per
application so my question was then um
if if we're only at 300 or so thousand
or or what have you is there any concern
that uh one application alone could
deplete the entire thing no we're over
500,000 in the fund right now and as of
July 1st it will be another 3 or 350
going into it so no I don't have any
concerns with that currently but yeah I
think isn't it isn't it possible though
as a a commissioner that you could go to
fiscal committee and request extra funds
to be placed in this had if you had an
emergency of some sort I I think that is
always an option yes okay representative
Murray followup uh thank you madam chair
um and is there a list of of allowable
costs for reimbursements there there are
and um some some of the things really
become frustrating that people will uh
submit and in some cases when they
haven't been seized questionable as to
why it's even happening quite frankly um
there have been animals that have been
seized and are still under the the
ownership of the uh the person who they
were seized from and those animals have
been spayed or neutered uh that's
certainly not a
reimbursable expense uh and probably
shouldn't have taken place at all others
are like vaccinations for rabies which
is not an
emergency per se so we do have a list
and we do have a an amount not to exceed
so if some rescue comes in and wants to
charge more than what's on the list they
don't get reimbursed for that so this
this is not something that is just
whatever you think you know you should
do know you have to make choices on how
you want to care for those those animals
um because this is not just whatever you
want to do followup and thank you and so
and just so I'm clear this is available
to anything from a bunny to a
horse uh yes yeah okay representative
Penza so I have a couple questions first
thank you to representative Bixby cuz um
some of us that are new didn't
understand the history so I thank you
for that backstory um just off the top
of your head doesn't need to be an exact
number can you tell me how much that
whole great Daye incident cost well
that didn't cost us anything but it was
you know and
again I'm going to say that I think
there were charges that were incurred
that wouldn't have been paid from here
that was in I I want to say and maybe
representative Bixby has a better memory
I want to say it they were saying it was
close to a half a million
dollars uh the uh the HS USA said that
they spent $3 million
what and and one of the reasons that we
put a lot of Department oversight in the
cost of care fund is because we were a
little bit dubious
yeah they were they were charging for
people from their National Organization
to fly back and forth and I'm assuming
that they were including hotel rooms and
and and things like that so there were a
lot of things going on in what they were
saying was the cost that we would never
allow in this fund okay couple um so
then my other question has to do with um
the amount so you said there's over
500,000 in there so if um let's say um
is there a point where it we don't keep
putting into the fund and if we draw off
the fund does that go back into General
funds how does that work it's a
budgetary item so it would be capped at
2 million so what I would expect is I
and I am quite confident I will not be
commissioner when the fund gets to $2
million but what a commissioner would do
is looking at the budget saying okay our
rate of spend has been x amount and if
we put y amount in will be over 200 and
would just request a smaller amount um
but what I would also assume is then
that you are correct if that in fact
there had been more money budgeted
there's going to be that safeguard that
uh simply the treasury is not going to
put the money into the fund okay
last real quick question sure why um why
don't we have this Act take effect
immediately and not 60
days uh I would be perfectly happy with
an amendment to um to have it take
effect immediately there was just I
didn't see that no and and this is
typical legislation saying 60 days this
is one that there's no need to notify
anybody there's no need to to wait for
60 days so um I I see absolutely no
reason not to amend that to take effect
upon passage thank you thank you
representative cron and then
Bixby uh thank you ma'am thank you
commissioner just to make sure I got it
straight in my head so the town seizes
an animal sends it to SPCA or whoever
they send it to for care currently the
town doesn't have the budget to do that
so they go to this fund so I'm sorry
there's so much no town town does not
have a budget for it so the state gives
them the money no so that's that is the
current problem well that's what I'm
saying that's the current I mean but the
town can't take that money to transfer
it to that organization and even if we
wrote them a check yeah say there was a
billing for $50,000 and we wrote them a
check for
$50,000 under the municipal budget act
that $50,000 would be seen as
unanticipated revenue and they still
would not have a budget line item to pay
that $50,000 couldn't do it okay I got
so that that's the problem and frankly
you know I should have caught it
somebody should have caught it I got you
but here we arees representative Bixby
yeah this is a just a a minor technical
thing so
the the line where the the knocking the
state veterinarian out of the review
that is it it's typical in legislation
that the commissioner get charged with
doing absolutely all of the work and it
is assumed that uh the commissioner will
then assign that to the appropriate
person in the department right exactly
what happens with this is the state
veterinarian does his review of it um
makes a recommendation to me and I sign
off on it I mean this actually sets up a
legislative problem where the two of us
could disagree and perhaps nothing would
get done because it doesn't give the
authority to anybody to make the
decision this anticipates that we would
both agree on everything and that's not
typical uh what is typical is that there
is one person who is responsible for
making a decision so a decision can be
made if there were three involved okay
that might be different
but um but even then okay any other
questions for the
commissioner seeing none thank you very
much for testifying on this bill this
afternoon and I call Heather Faria from
organizations good afternoon uh thank
you for hearing my testimony Madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
Heather Faria I am the vice president of
the New Hampshire Federation of Humane
organ organizations and the executive
director of the Pope Memorial SPCA here
in
conquer uh the New Hampshire Federation
of Humane
organizations um we are um a group of
New Hampshire rescues SPCA and Humane
Societies often partnered with
municipalities and charged with taking
care of animals um in the situation that
you just heard the commissioner describe
so through our Municipal Partnerships we
often take custody of animals that have
been seized
um and we provide the care that has been
requested for the duration of
Investigations and trials through the
final
dissolution um so we are those third
parties that would potentially be
awaiting payment um so what this bill
would allow is um for the payment to
come directly to us um really that's the
only change so the municipality would
still be charged with completing the
application providing all the proper
documentation meeting the requ
requirements of the application it would
simply allow the funds to come directly
to us rather than back to the
municipality and then through their
process and to us as the commissioner
described um we are obviously as you
would anticipate very much in favor of
this bill and hope that you would
consider uh passing it and I'd be happy
to answer any questions thank you uh
representa Murray thank you m Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question is there a situation that I I
just want to make sure if if a
reimbursement came to you then would you
then notify the town or M municipality
that you've received reimbursement and
you're
expecting I I'm just trying to figure
out because a bill would have been sent
right to the municipality of for
something sure and so sorry yep go ahead
so it' be like any other bill you would
receive we would Bill them they would
understand that there's an outstanding
balance and when we receive payment um
we would send we would send them notice
like you would if you when you pay
something you receive notice that that
has been paid and so um that would be
standard um for them to
know any other
questions no seeing none thank you very
much okay appreciate it of course thank
you and uh Jen
Zella oh you have copies of your
testimony oh you can pass it around if
you like or just give it to the
clerk no no don't pass it around pass it
around
okay yeah thank you jenella from the
governor's committee on Humane treatment
of animals sorry you can't read my
writing it's okay my name is uh Jerry
Zula and I'm co-chair of the governor's
Commission on the Humane treatment of
animals I did send in written testimony
on your portal but I thought I would
come and um speak a little bit about how
important
this um cost of care is to us to keep
tabs on and make sure that it's going to
work to its fullest extent uh
commissioner Jasper covered covered it
very well uh representative Bixby talked
a lot about the history of the need of
it and I can answer more questions
related to that because it actually goes
back to um the 2008 report that the
governor's Comm Mission did on the cost
analysis of animal cruelty in New
Hampshire and it was at that time that
we recognized that many
towns were hesitant to pursue cruelty
cases to their fullest because of the
cost to the towns and this is both with
um primarily
with large numbers of animals hoarding
cases and things like that because that
can just break the budget um to even
some of the more expensive single or
double animals um where a town did not
have anything budgeted for any of this
it can break the bank and we found that
they were often um actually leaving
animals in the custody of the owner when
they shouldn't have been to save the
town money um we found that um often
times they
were not Prosecuting they were getting
the people to turn over the animals and
not prosecute just so that they could
not have to pay long term um for the
care of the animals so we were
um worked on trying to figure out ways
to do this and and your committee was uh
the one that got it passed and we were
very anxious um and happy that that was
done um it was a lot of work we had been
through years of discussion about this
and how to do it um we were looking at
the um the the victims compensation laws
we were looking at a lot of different
things to come up with this so uh
commissioner Jasper's been very good and
shared with us some of the applications
and what's going on and um we'll
continue to do so so that we can kind of
te cabs on this but it did become
apparent that this extra step or extra
two steps because sometimes there's more
than one third party in involved um so
that uh it'll help tremendously to have
the process work better because the town
doesn't have to have any initial output
it can go directly to the third
parties thank you any
questions representative Murray uh thank
so I just want to make sure that I'm
clear in the accounting portion of this
if you're saying there's could be one or
two third party entities that then could
be
reimbursed um is it is there any
situation where
there where's that oversight being held
is that at the department level or is
that then at the cost of care fund or
the way that the application is there
has to be receipts sent in for
everything and that's still going to be
the responsibility of the town but let's
say that the animals are housed in a
humane society that doesn't have a
veterinarian but in a veterinarian needs
to go in and do some emergency work
there may be two bills one from the
Humane Society or shelter and one from
the veterinarian so that the cost of
care fund could pay each individually
rather than reimburse the town and then
have the town have to figure out how to
pay those two third parties
or okay any other questions from the
committee no seeing none thank you
appreciate it is there anyone else who
bill okay we got the blue
sheet on the online portal there's 10 in
support
zero people
opposed on yeah 10 on the blue sheet we
have two in favor and none
opposed with that I'm going to close out
and
[Music]
um I know that
um we had heard something from um
representative Penza about um perhaps
amending this bill to say um the ACT
should take effect immediately after
passage but um I mean unless you guys
want to come back and exec one bill
uh if anybody is interested in executing
um do do I hear a
motion um well I think that uh we have a
we have another hearing that's supposed
to start at um 1:30 so I EXA this
afterno we can EXA this afternoon after
we do the hearing on the other sounds
like a plan okay with that I'm going to
open up the hearing for s sp5 45
establishing a committee to study the
scope and role of Veterinary
technicians and I have both a card for
uh Senator Su Prentice but I also have a
card for Jenny Horan I believe you're
representing Senator Apprentice to
introduce the bill that is fine with me
if it's fine with the rest of the
committee yeah go right ahead wonderful
so my name is Jenny Horan I am the
policy director for the Senate
Democratic caucus sen Apprentice
apologizes um there are a lot of
hearings going on today and
unfortunately she couldn't be here but
if it's all right with the chair and the
members I can read some testimony that
she provided to me and then I know Rob
Johnson is also here who's been deeply
involved in the bill so please proceed
me thank you so during the pandemic many
graned Staters turned to New Hampshire
farms for their food supply trusted
Community Partners the backbone of New
Hampshire I can remember driving up to
Piper Hill Road in Claremont and seeing
a line outside lir Farmstead in
planfield magnam Dairy and Riverview
Farms my point when we needed the
agricultural Community they were there
for us now they need us the legislature
to be there for them livestock producers
all across the us including here in New
Hampshire are dealing with a serious
shortage of large and food animal
veterinarians according to the USDA in
2023 the shortage of rural veterinarians
has reached an all-time high with 500
counties in 46 States deemed as having a
critical shortage of large animal vets
the shortfall posed poses risk not only
to livestock and Farmers but the
country's food supply unfortunately it
looks like the shortage is only going to
deepen as a pipeline for new
veterinarians especially those who
specialize in large and agricultural
animals continues to stagnate over the
past six months I have been engaged in
conversations about how to address New
Hampshire's emerging large animal
veterinarian shortage as of octo um
August 31st 2023 the northernmost Large
Animal Clinic in the state is closed its
stores leaving a large portion of the
state with even less access to Services
I learned recently that a large animal
veterinarian practice in my district is
preparing to close we need both a
short-term and a long-term approach over
the past few months I have engaged
stakeholders and discussions including
the New Hampshire Farm Bureau Federation
large and small animal veterinarians the
Department of Agriculture and the office
of professional lure and
certification while we don't yet have a
long-term solution the role of veter
Aran text in the field was a point of
consensus and at and that we may be able
to enhance their roles to create some re
relief for the large animal
veterinarians Senate Bill 545 proposes
to study the Vette Tech role and
opportunities that could benefit the
system of care for our large animals our
food animals this bill includes key
questions about the current and
potential future role and who we need
Who We Believe needs to be at the table
to best inform the legislature thank you
for allowing me the time to bring this
forward to your attention and Advance
one pathway towards a solution
so again I would ask you defer any
questions our Apprentice is more than
happy to answer any I'm happy to take
back to
her okay representative K thank you
madam chair and thank you for coming
here but could I have a that testimony
for the record of course absolutely okay
any questions thank you um
representative Bixby yeah so um this is
coming to us now as a um as a study
committee bill it was initially uh
submitted in the Senate as a bill to
just do it uh what were what were the
impediments to going ahead with it uh as
it was written in the Senate yeah no
thank you so much for the question
represent I think Rob has been deeply
involved in that process and would be
much better suited to answer that
question me I will put that off remember
that question Mr
Johnson okay any other questions seeing
none thank you for introducing the bill
and we uh give our regards to Senator
Apprentice we do thank you thank you
I'll call Rob Johnson from uh New
Bureau thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire farmer
was a federation's policy director and
we we uh do support uh Senate Bill 545
we we have worked with Senate Apprentice
on the bill I'll kind of start with
answering representative Dix's question
first I just ask you to move the
microphone closer thank you excuse me
the the bill is introduced uh
established a uh large animal veterinary
incentive uh payment program and the
goal of such programs are to incentivize
large animal veterinary veterinarians to
practice in an underserved area uh
Senator apprentices bill incentivized
veterinarians to practice in the
northern part of the state by
reimbursing a percentage of their
veterinary school tuition if they agreed
to practice in the region for a period
of time and I believe the the bills
introduced was a a 20% payment for each
three years that they agreed uh as there
is a similar Federal program already
being funded that has not been utilized
in New Hampshire it was it was our uh
agreement that is introduced it had
little chance of moving forward so when
it's place the senator introduced this
bill after consult with us we uh our
president Joyce Brady has named a group
it's kind of a we'll call it a task
force that initially met this past fall
with a representative from the New
Hampshire VMA a representative from the
the uh uh uh the uh what's the group I
want to say the the vet tax Association
the state veterinarian uh number of our
leaders and some of their veterinarians
kind of just spit fball looking at this
issue what can we do and this and that
and this was one of the the ideas that
had come up we had the a couple of our
members their veterinarians have
suggested that maybe the The Lure of vet
Tex would uh the thought being would
provide a higher level of training that
would make veterinarians more
comfortable in in giving these
technicians greater responsibilities
because in the end they're working
basically off of the the veterinarians
licenses at least as I understand it and
we and now all this would help reduce
the the vet vets workload and you know I
we've heard from we've heard some
veterinarians who tell us it's not going
to help and we've heard others that
think it's a good idea so that's why we
said well let's study it let's get all
the players in a in a room and really
take a look at that to see if it will do
anything so that that's that's where it
came about and just let me give you a
little bit of background on the whole
this whole vet shortage and I as as
Senate Apprentice said in her uh remarks
that were read that this is not unique
to New Hampshire it's not it's
Nationwide and it's it's isn't something
that just happened overnight it's been
been ongoing but um I was looking at a a
uh it's an agricultural consultant firm
that that it's the Van Trump report that
that is that is widely read and they had
an article a few months back entitled
America's large animal veterinarian
shortage is barreling towards crisis
levels uh to give you an idea and and it
and it cites a report that was authored
in 2022 by a Cornell University
Economist Clinton yel uh and which he he
put together for the farm Journal
Foundation that found that only about 3
to 4% of new veterinary school graduates
pursue livestock or other food Animal
Practice areas 40 years ago that number
was 40% just 40 years ago
in 2003 the
avma uh statistics show that of the
82,791
per practice primarily delivering care
to animals raised for food food or Fiber
another 4.1% practice uh uh delivering
care to equids to equines donkeys that
type
uh another seven and a half percent are
are are dual practice companion and
large animal while a a vast majority
over 70% uh primarily practice uh
delivering to equin uh uh the equin
community why is the
shortage on average veterinary school
graduates finish school nearly
$200,000 in debt the better pay in more
reasonable work hours that go with a
practice focusing primarily or
exclusively on companion animals is
attractive to a profession having the
added stress of dealing with animal
owners in life and death s situations on
a regular basis there's a physical toll
experience working with large animals
not to mention inherent
dangers a mental toll also from
exhaustion and working a regular hours
day and night especially when you're
dealing with you know emergencies that
that that many livestock owners have on
occasion uh as well as a considerable
amount of of driving time in rural areas
as veterinarians when they're talking to
tell they call it windshield
time you know um and driving to these
appointments make days even longer all
this easily leads to burnout in the
industry both from the job and just the
lifestyle in
general also a factor is that 63% of of
vet school graduates are female while
37% are
men as an oldtime veterinarian said to
me not long ago women are a lot smarter
than us men they value work life balance
as they should and realize they can make
double the money caring for companion
animals Madam chair I'll leave it at
that and we ask that you approve this
study thank
you any questions from the
committee representative H Haskins thank
you madam chair I don't know if you can
answer this uh and it may not be
Germaine but I think I read that there's
a conglomeration going on where
corporate entities are buying up small
Veterinary practices is this does this
feed into the problem do you know I
believe it's a
factor um that that's something
we are trying to look at actually our
our organization New Hampshire Farm
Bureau we adopted a resolution this past
year asking our National Organization to
to uh actually put some pressure on USDA
to conduct a study on that very issue
and we the reason we asked for USDA to
do it uh years ago USDA conducted a
study a separate issue but a rural
healthc care and and so we thought well
this is similar only with animals so and
they have the resources to do it but yes
I think the that's a excellent question
I think I think it probably is a factor
in in certain regards representative
Bixby yeah I have a small technical
question which I don't uh I mentioned it
to rep to Senator Pearl um and but I
don't know if uh this is something that
you would weigh in or not we weigh in on
or not but uh the as written uh the bill
from the Senate says that it's going to
be a thre member study committee uh and
um I was wondering if there would be any
objection to making that for members so
that a three- member committee with a
three- member Quorum would uh and that
seem the three members three member
Quorum seems like a recipe for failed
meetings and by adding another member I
think we might be able to make that a
little bit more resilient no objection
okay okay represent
Katon thank you madam chair thank you
for Testimony what I what I didn't know
was that you had tapped my phone when I
was talking to my daughter she graduated
from vet school and loves horses but is
not working with horses um my question
though is on your on this subcommittee
what would you envision as an outcome
what what would you expect them to come
back
with i i conceptually yeah a
recommendation of whether or not it
makes sense to pursue licens
of of that tax there there is licensure
in some states uh but for a followup
that's that's the core of what we're
we're looking for and then and that
licensure would
gain what capability that we don't have
now yeah that the I guess the the the
thinking at least from some of the
discussions some of our members we've
had with with veterinarians it would be
a a higher level of training the
certification that would make
veterinarians feel more comfortable
in in um
uh giving responsibility to the vet Tex
because really that the techs are
working under the veterinarian's license
and if they have that extra training you
know liability wise and that type of
thing that that's the thought process
behind it whether that's true or not
that's why they kind studying right Goa
okay
thanks representative
smart thank you madam chair uh in the
states that do require LIC for vetex how
many of those vetex are actually working
with um agriculture animals yeah that
that's a fair question I couldn't tell
you I couldn't even tell you how many
states I haven't looked at it studied it
how many are have licensure
at representative ktoa thank than you
madam chair and uh thank you for taking
my question it's kind of question
comment type uh deal so currently in the
state of New Hampshire we have a
shortage of veterinarians whether it
being small animal or large animal I do
believe would you say that is
correct I haven't I don't know about the
uh companion animal that there may well
be but I there is it's it's it's
certainly
I I don't think it's of the magnitude of
the large animal at least from what I've
heard I know that our members who are
having trouble finding a a a
veterinarian veteran service it's with
their their livestock not with their
companion animals okay um and thank you
for that and obviously I mean I
understand uh the value of uh large
animal vet I mean there is no amount of
money that um uh someone that has one uh
can actually put on uh when they need
the care and uh personally uh having my
vet come out on 4th of July on a Sunday
or at midnight uh when it's freezing uh
to to care for an animal is just amazing
and so I can understand why a lot of
people uh kind of cater to the enclosed
climate controlled uh Companion Animal
um when looking at this do you think
that um currently a licens your system
may look something similar to the
nursing program where you could have
like a lower Tech than kind of like the
LNA the RNA you know it kind of like a
stepping stone um and maybe not
everything has to be done through
schooling but could be done through
experience because I think
experience um especially from a highly
trained veterinarian goes a long way um
because nothing can be said for
experience uh do you see the committee
looking at a structure similar to that c
certainly uh it's interesting you you
asked that question because recently I
was talking with somebody about this
issue and and they mentioned one concern
that some texts they've heard have is
that that the the in effect by having
license your own State de facto it's a
requirement
and and would so would there be the
ability I don't know if it's that way in
other states that have it if there is
the ability to be you know be a license
vet teet an non-licensed vet tech I I
don't know that's Again part of the
reason that we're looking at the
study Madam chair if you I have one more
item I can mention to you that that kind
of maybe lends a little bit of Hope to
this whole issue um that just recently
the the avma the American vet Medical
Association uh if I can find it here
which
uh they are responsible for accrediting
Veterinary Medical Schools they they had
a was a press release where they
announced that there are 14 proposed new
veterinary colleges around the country
and and you may say well that's not that
many but when you think we only have 33
now uh 14 and even if half of them uh go
through the process would really be a
boom so there is a array of Hope though
that's down the road a
bit good to know all right any other
questions questions for uh Mr
Johnson seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony is there anyone else
who wishes to speak on this
bill uh do we have a count for but there
were five people online u in in support
of the bill all support all support no
opposition and on the blue sheet we have
one person in
support with that I'm going to close out
545 so
uh I guess we can talk about executing
this bill and um the bill that we heard
prior SB
385 and
um I guess we could we should do s SP
545 first and I believe that um
representative Bixby has an amendment
to that bill which increases the uh size
of this study committee by one
person so that um in a situation where
they need a quorum of
three they will have four people on the
committee instead of three so' already
amendment he mentioned it well he he put
He has yeah he he already drafted that
with um
OS and so um I would like to open up the
exact session for S SP 545 if that's
okay with everybody yeah and uh
representative Bixby I believe has a a
motion yes so uh I'd like to uh on a
motion of OTP I'd like to offer the uh
following Amendment um Amendment s uh
4-1 1492 H we want to adopt that right y
yes adopt amend
and representative kraton seconds okay
and may I speak I second you may speak
to the amendment okay so um as as I
alluded to in during testimony um the
bill as it as it came to us had uh two
house members and one Senate member and
a quorum of three uh experienced in the
past has been that it is not uncommon
for not all of the members of a study
committee to make it on every
occasion uh so uh I thought that it
would be prudent to add one more um
member to the committee from the House
of
Representatives uh and in consultant in
consultation with our chair uh we
decided that it would make sense to make
that uh that second new member of it uh
a member of our committee so we'll so
the amendment has two members from uh
Ena one member from uh uh envir um
executive departments Administration and
one Senate member and that's what the
amendment
does representative comto thank you
madam chair um I wholeheartedly concur
with this amendment um from
experience um and it is essential that
you have three members from the house um
in my personal in my
experience agree any other discussion on
this
amendment seeing none I'd like the clerk
to take a call uh roll call on um
adopting this amendment thank you madam
chair we're adopting 2024
1492 H representative kraton I represent
coma yes represent Davis yes represent
Kenny yes represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
Duty representative M oh she's not
here okay representative Murray yes
representative jamna yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard yes represent
yes 14
180 amendment is adopted okay do I hear
a
motion I would like to move otpa with
Amendment uh 2024 d492 H representative
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion represent
Bixby um so I think that uh from what we
just heard in testimony it makes makes
an awful lot of sense to study this it
will uh resolve some of the questions
that came up in uh during the course of
testimony and I think that this is this
is a real problem that needs to be
addressed okay representative kto thank
you madam chair this is also a very Hot
Topic at the uh Governor's Commission on
the Humane treatment of animals and uh
because of the shortage uh not only in
large animal but also in companied
animal veteran errand
anyone
else okay seeing no uh request for
further comment I would ask the clerk to
call the role thank you madam chair this
is an otpa on Sb OH I have the wrong
Bill 545 thank you um representative
kraton I
54 uh representative ktoa yes
representative Davis yes representative
Kenny yes representative Penza yes
represent smart represent Bixby yes
representa Murray represent
J yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
Morris Madam chair yes
140 shall It Go on consent no
objection okay I'll call close the exec
on uh SB
545 and um would the committee entertain
executing s SP 385 relative to the cost
of care
fund any
objection all right so I'll open the
385 and wait let me get to the uh the
bill
here okay do I hear a motion represent
kraton I move ought to pass on SB 385 I
hear a second represent Bixby I'll
second
that okay any would you like to speak to
your
motion I just refer back to the
testimony I think it's a good idea and
we should move
forward
okay thank you uh any discussion on this
bill represent viby um I think that uh
having been involved with the initial
creation of the cost of care fun I I
think that uh the these minor
corrections to it make an awful lot of
sense and we should um pass
it
okay make it so uh OTP on SB 385
representative kraton I represent coma
yes representative
Davis represent Kenny yes represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby
yes representative Murray yes represent
Jama yes represent H Haskins I represent
Howard yes represent NAB yes represent
moris Madame chair yes 140 shall It Go
on
consent
yes and I close out the exec session for
S SP 385 and that completes our work on
these four Senate bills today um we have
no other Sen bills ahead of us at this
time so uh at this time our work is
complete for the
Year and thank you all for your work on
these mention our field trip on the T
and we have a field trip scheduled for
May 3rd which representative kraton
would you like to fill everybody in on
yeah we're going to it's it's a redo
from last month that we got snowed out
uh we're going to waste management and
Rochester
starts at 9:00 goes till
10:30 and um I will send out uh the
details and and another invite um
probably by the end of this week so
everyone's got on your counter but May
3rd 9:00 we meet there they've got a bus
there they take us around show us all
the trash and what other better way
could you spend and with trash so invite
everyone to join us
okay representive comto thank you and
also on that same day is the farm and
Forest Expo uh over at the Deerfield
yes dress code for the landfill do you
represent jeans jeans and rubber boots
uh could you just send us the details on
that on the Deerfield Farm yeah I I will
send I will send out the information
about that um I know that we get we get
some free tickets or something from the
Department of Agriculture uh uh
commissioner Jasper sent me an email
about that um I think it was last week
so what I will do is I'll make sure I
get that out to everybody okay
all
right represent ktoa yeah so if you can
go on to New Hampshire far en Forest
expo.org too to get all the information
and find out who the exhibitors and
everything are also and I would like to
remind um representative NAB kraton and
Bixby to get me your committee reports
for the bills that we exact today as
soon as you
can
and p.m and on the p.m and on the
Saturday the 4th it's 9:00 a.m. to 400
p.m. okay all right one other thing I
know that representative Bixby did you
want to discuss this or in private or um
I want to discuss it with you first oh
discuss it with me okay but I think um
it's there's a little bit there's still
a little bit of
um
uh disagreement about the and um so I
think that we we might that um rather
than it being um signed by the as a the
committee as a whole that any members of
the committee you want to sign on it on
to it uh would uh for the names to you
and then those signatures go on
as this letter was um being sent to them
um I I I didn't have an any um
expectation that everybody had a
signature in in other words a physical
signature on the letter it was just um
written by me you know
well it was going to be sent uh from me
to our our uh Federal delegation um
members and um I guess you know just
writing on behalf of our committee based
on the information of regarding that
bill
so I think maybe maybe we should you and
I should discuss and
then okay because I don't think that
we're going to I think I don't know that
full committee discussion is going to
that I mean I could write it just from
me and not from the entire committee
that's okay too
um okay so
um let's you I
discuss all right with that I'm going to
adjourn our meeting for this afternoon
and if I hear from any uh you know any
further Senate bills I will schedule a
meeting uh uh a further meeting in the
future but as of this time we have no
other uh committee meeting scheduled uh
to deal with any Senate bills um so
we'll see our work could be finished
know representative smart do I need to
use my microphone yeah sure okay do um
how do we H who determines the committee
for SB 545 and how do the
representatives no I mean so the uh the
speaker if the bill gets passed through
the house which it'll be on consent so
my my guess is the Bill gets passed
however uh the Senate would have to
concur with it which I'm sure they will
and then the governor would have to sign
it if it gets signed into law then what
happens is uh the speaker of the house
would assign uh the people to be on this
committee
um what the speaker has requested when
we do these study committees now is that
we
recommend uh individuals from our
committee to be considered for
membership of the sub of the study
committee and normally uh the person who
um who uh introduced or proposed the
bill would Al I would imagine Senator
prenis pennis would be chosen to be uh
the Senate member on the committee so
yeah
okay
down representative Bixby yeah just a
little more clarification on that
process so um did I get it wrong uh you
didn't you covered most of the ground
but it's a because it's a Senate Bill
the Senate member will be the convening
member yes um and then which is NI um
and because we specify which committees
uh people will come come from it is uh
the the speaker will have to choose two
people from our committee and one from
Edna and uh typically what happens is
that um the chair uh will um we'll make
the we'll make recommendations to the
speaker and then the speaker will um
listen to the chair's recommendations
that doesn't always happen but it it
usually happens so so that that's the
basic process so when you say the chair
I'm talking about Judy Judy yeah the the
chair of this committee will make the
recommendations for two members from
this committee and uh so anybody so once
it once the governor signs it um Judy
will probably send out a email saying uh
is anybody interested and if you're
interested then maybe I'll ask today who
your who's who's
you get two
people you are V right get two vets but
smart Kenny and then I think Alison is
Alison okay that's good to know so all
right um yeah so that that probably okay
so um and then someone from Edna who can
talk about lure yeah and then the oh the
other thing I was going to mention is
that uh depending on when the governor
signs it it actually is conceivable that
it could happen uh that it could be uh
start earlier than in the fall uh if the
Senate member chooses to um to convene
before then for an organization meeting
right uh no actually not in July no it
would have to be after August I believe
well
no or before like June 10th yeah so it
could be it can be so basically July is
pretty much blacked out and August is
mostly blacked out from doing
legislative business so it could start
before either in June or then we start
um on another
subject just before we we leave all
leave um I want
to I want to check on something here
because um we had a a
um Homestead food bill to Homestead food
bills in our
committee and um one of them was we
changed the language so that it would
expand the offerings of um uh of foods
that could be sold at Homestead food
stands to be pickles salsa relishes
remember that um and that bill is going
to be heard um this Thursday in the
Senate
um with that being said I know that we
had discussed about having establishing
a food safety subcommittee
and I have names down here to be on that
subcommittee as myself representative
bxby representative kulan representative
ktoa representative sofikitis and
representative
Murray and um I would imagine we would
um I don't know how soon we could get
together and have meetings to discuss
with uh D DHHS Food Safety Division
that's Colleen Smith and Abigail Rogers
uh talking to talk to them about the
possibilities of um further expansion of
the um Homestead food safety legislation
rsas to at least look at them because I
know um people have dis have uh come to
us in various forms to say that uh the
food uh lure laws are confused
and uh would like to have us take a look
at that and see where we can make some
clarifications where we might be able to
make some expansions and make some
changes in those rsas so that's what
this subcommittee would would be engaged
in doing representative Bixby now I
believe that we uh voted that the second
of those bills um interim study right
and so this subcommittee would be
looking at that looking at that and uh
typically so we
can uh start working on uh interim study
bills before the fall ju uh but we can't
do it in July or August but we can start
we could do it in May or June if the
speaker lets us right uh and that is
often a matter of uh whether the speaker
perceives the resources such as this
room and us as being uh otherwise
constrained or whether we would be a
whether this room will be free and
whether the members of the subcommittee
would be free um it my guess is that the
members of the subcommittee would be
free uh and I don't it's so um unless
there's some conflict with Committees of
conference using this room I I think
that it would be feasible to to uh to
start working on it before summer and it
might be nice to get that sort of off
you know off the table off the table
uh but we can't do it unless the speaker
lets us exactly so that's your job yeah
no I'll I'll speak to I will speak to um
speaker Packard about it and see how
soon that we can get started either on
that interim study or at least looking
at um those statutes so yeah we'll we'll
take care of that all right well thank
you everybody appreciate it and um if I
don't see you have a nice
summer all right but
we'll all we'll see everybody on the
third yeah
absolutely for for our garbage tour yeah